leslie david baker who portrayed
salesman stanley hudson is only one of
five actors to appear in every single
episode of the office though stan lee
might not be the first character that
fans might associate with the series he
joins names like dwight schrute played
by rayne wilson and jim halpert
portrayed by john krasinski on that
exclusive list of true dunder mifflin
mainstays while the office came to a
close in 2013 baker's career remains
defined in large part by the show in
fact baker revealed to tomorrow comes
movies at the 2018 los angeles comic con
that he would be open to an office
reunion and he even began attempting to
finance a spin-off about stanley through
kickstarter in 2020 in fact the
kickstarter campaign ultimately raised
enough money to shoot a pilot for the
series titled uncle stan the show aims
to focus on the relationship between
stanley and his nephew lucky who comes
to his uncle for guidance when he starts
up his own hybrid florist motorcycle
business sadly since 2020 there's been
no word on uncle stan however like most
of his co-stars baker continues to enjoy
the enduring passion of fans of the
office even if that means indulging in
some of their less than convincing
theories that are widely shared online
speaking of one such pretty unbelievable
theory what if stanley isn't merely a
reliable supporting player in the office
but actually the show's low-key most
important character according to a
highly unlikely yet oddly compelling fan
theory shared on reddit approximately
half of the office episodes might take
place not in reality but within
stanley's psyche according to a reddit
user who appropriately shared their idea
to the fan theories subreddit a season 5
episode of the office titled stress
relief might be the most important one
in the show's run in the episode's cold
open dwight purposefully lights a fire
in a trash can in order to set off the
office's smoke alarms and test his
co-workers fire preparedness in the
ensuing chaos stanley suffers a heart
attack he ultimately appears to survive
without issue and is back at work after
a short break no no no you will not die
daily stanley you will not die the
redditor however theorizes that
stanley's heart attack was fatal
everything in the office from the
moments following the opening credits of
stress relief to its series finale
represents stanley in hell and his
supposed co-workers are now demons
imitating his one-time office mates this
theory hinges on two assumptions that
the mishaps in dunder mifflin are
particularly torturous for stanley and
that the behaviors of various characters
shift significantly in and after stress
relief in the wildly far-fetched theory
the redditor argues stanley was the
person who enjoyed being at the office
the least most often refusing to take
part in whenever shenanigans were being
cooked up hell for him is the office but
worse
[Music]
i'm going to die
one could argue if you buy the initial
theory that vague hints are placed
throughout the show the most notable
takes place in the season six episode
secret santa there's an exchange between
stanley and michael scott where stanley
opens a gift a scented candle and
michael taunts stanley with the argument
that he'll be facing punishment for
cheating on his wife michael says a lot
of fire where you're going better get
used to it
you're going to hell double hockey
sticks going to hell stanley to be fair
stanley does appear to be perpetually
grumpy of course as with so many fan
theories this one begins to collapse
under scrutiny since plenty of moments
that ensue both good and bad don't
concern him whatsoever some other reddit
users as usual raised concerns with the
theory for instance one wrote the last
time i checked hell doesn't reward
people with free meatballs alternatively
another user took things to the next
level and wrote creed is clearly satan
if your theory holds any validity killed
a guy that crossed him and took his name
and identity no morals to speak of i
feel like i'm working in my own casket
the truth is that fan theories are
purely theories they usually don't make
sense but they provide a fun way to
re-watch old episodes and as it is with
many fan theories the creative minds
behind the office almost certainly did
not plan most of the show's run to make
it look like it was stanley's personal
hell particularly since there is no such
revelation contained in the final
episode nonetheless a watch through of
episodes after stanley's heart attack
with this theory in mind can shed
entirely new light onto what is for many
an old favorite
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]